ساعات تفصل الولايات المتحده عن انتخابات
التجديد النصفي لتعود معها اتهامات
بالتدخل الروسي مخاوف بين المسؤولين
الامريكيين من لعبه روسيه قد تغير مسار
الانتخابات وتتلاعب باهواء الامريكيين
باحثون امريكيون يتهمون عملاء روسيين
مشتبهان بهم باستخدام منصات تابعه لاقصى
اليمين بهدف تشويه سمعه بعض المرشحين
الديمقراطيين في عده ولايات ما دفع الحرس
الوطني الامريكي لابداء استعداد خبراء
السيبرانيين لتقديم الدعم والحمايه
الالكترونيه لمسؤولين حكوميين في 14 ولايه
روسيا ومنذ اتهامها بالتدخل في انتخابات
الى خوف الحزب الديمقراطي من الهزيمه في
الانتخابات النصفيه
[موسيقى]
وبالرغم من النفي الروسي الا ان فوز بعض
الجمهوريين قد يكونوا ورقه راضحه لموسكو
والتي تخوض دوامه الحرب الاوكرانيه منذ
اشهر
عدد من الجمهوريين التمويل الذي تقدمه
الحكومه
في ظل التضخم الذي تعيشه البلاد والازمه
العالميه التي افرزتها الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
تصريحات وجمهوريه تبين الانقسام في الحزب
ففي الوقت الذي يعارض فيه بعض النواب
الداعمين لترامب استمرار الدعم الامريكي
لاوكرانيا يدعو اخرون الى زيادهته ليؤكد
المحللون ان فوز الجمهوريين لن يهدي بوتن
نصرا من ذهب في اوكرانيا مشددين على
استمرار دعم الحسبين لكيف ابن عمر العربيه